The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANDREI BARBU: All right.
To start off with, perception
is a very difficult problem.
And there's a good reason why
perception should be difficult,
right?
We get a very
impoverished stimulus.
We get, like a 2D array
of values from a 3D scene.
Given this
impoverished stimulus,
we have to understand
a huge amount of stuff
about the world.
We have to understand the
3D structure of the world.
If you look at
any one pixel, you
have to understand the
properties of the surface that
produce the elimination
that gave you that pixel.
You have to understand
the color or the texture.
You have to see the
color of the light that
hit that surface, the roughness
of the surface, et cetera.
So you have a very small
channel, a very small window
onto the world, and you have
to extract a tremendous amount
of information so that
you can survive and not
get killed by cars regularly.
All right.
That's exactly the
problem we're going
to talk about here,
which is, how do we
use our knowledge of the world
to structure our perception?
To actually modify
what we see in order
to be able to
solve this problem?
How do we take a small
impoverished stimulus
and extract a huge
amount of information
about the world around us?
So let's start
with a few examples
where knowledge about the
world really, practically
changes what we see.
So I'm Canadian.
So I'm required to show you a
Canadian flag in every talk.
Here we are.
You can take this flag and
you can give it to any of you.
You can give it to any
kid and you can ask them,
here's a marker.
Put big red marks around
the regions on this flag
or in the regions in
this image that are red.
And it's pretty
clear to all of us
that there is a distinction
between the red that's
in the flag, and the bars,
and in the Maple Leaf,
versus the red that's
actually in the background.
And we can all tell
those two apart.
Except if you actually
look at the pixel values,
you open them in Photoshop, or
GIMP, or whatever other program
you want, you're going to notice
that those pixel values are
actually not
particularly different.
There's no threshold
that you can
choose that will separate
the red on the flag
from the red in the background.
so you're doing a huge
amount of inference
just to solve this
trivial, little problem of,
what color is where?
You're using knowledge
about regions, knowledges
about flags, knowledge
about transparency,
in order to figure out
that the red flag is
different from the
red in the background.
So this is a really
practical way
that your knowledge
about the world
really changes your perception.
You're not seeing the colors
that are really there.
Another nice example comes from
a paper by Antonino Torralba.
So if you look at the
scene, it's pretty blurry.
And it has to be blurry
because your visual system is
so incredibly good, we have
to degrade the input for you
to see how poor it
actually is if we take away
some information.
So this looks like a scene.
And the background
looks like a building.
In the foreground, you can
there's maybe a street.
And the thing on the street
kind of looks like a car.
Does it look like
a car to everybody?
Awesome.
We can look at a
slightly different image.
very similar scene.
Again, same building
in the background,
same street in the foreground.
Now, there's kind of a
blob in the foreground.
And it looks as
if it's a person.
It looks like a person
to everyone, right?
Awesome.
Well, the only
problem is the blob
on the left is exactly the
same as the blob on the right.
It's difficult to believe me,
but you can find these two
images online and in his paper.
You can open them up in
your favorite image viewer.
You can zoom in and
you'll see they are
pixelized completely identical.
So you're using a tremendous
amount of information
to put together the fact that
buildings and streets-- when
you see these horizontal
streaks, it means a car.
And when you see these vertical
streaks, it means people.
And this really changes
how you see the world.
And it changes it to the point
where you actually, probably
don't believe me that these
two blobs are the same.
And I couldn't believe
it either until I
really zoomed in and checked.
So you can see lots
of interesting effects
where your high-level
knowledge of the world
is structuring your
low-level perception,
and it is actually
overriding it.
You've seen this example
with the hammer, where
you were unable to
recognize what's
going on in a small region.
But when I give you the
rest of the context,
you can tell that it's a hammer.
And when you see
the whole video,
you actually don't see
the hammer disappear.
You're filling in information
from context in single images
and you're filling
in information
from context in whole videos.
But if we dig in what's going
on here just a little bit more,
what's going on is
somewhere inside your head,
there's something resembling
a hammer detector, right?
So you run a hammer detector.
And you ran that hammer detector
over that little region.
And it said, I'm not so sure.
I'm not very
confident about what
I see in this little region.
And somewhere inside
your head, there's
some detector or something that
can recognize someone hammering
something.
So if we look at sort of a more
traditional computer vision
pipeline, what you
would do is you
would run your hammer detector.
You would take your
hammer detector.
You would use that
knowledge in order
to recognize hammering
in the scene.
And at the end,
you would say, I'm
really confused because
my hammer detector
didn't work very well.
The reason why you
can actually do this
is because you have a feedback.
You were able to recognize the
hammering event as a whole.
And that lets you
upgrade the scores
of your hammer
detector, which is
very unreliable in this case.
So feedback was really
critical in being
able to understand this scene.
Unfortunately, pretty much
all of computer vision
is feed forward, even though
most of your visual system
has, for the most part,
feedback connections.
More feedbacks
than feed forwards.
So in this talk, we're going
to talk about that feedback.
And we're going to
see a way that we're
going to build this feedback
in a principled way.
That if we choose
right detections--
right algorithms and
right representations
from our low-level
perception, we're
going to be able to combine it
with our high-level perception
of the world.
So we've seen that perception
is very unreliable.
The top-down knowledge really
affects your perception.
And that, what you're
going to see in a moment,
is that one integrated
representation
can be used for many tasks.
The advantage of these feedbacks
goes beyond just better vision.
It lets you solve a lot
of different problems
that look very, very distinct.
But actually, turn out
to be very, very similar.
So one problem is recognition.
I can give you a picture of
a chair, and I can tell you,
what is this?
And you can tell
me it's a chair.
Or I can give you a picture
and I can give you a sentence,
this is a chair.
And you can tell
me, I believe you.
This is true.
There's also a completely
different problem,
which is retrieval.
Related to recognition, right?
How about I give you
a library of videos
and ask you to find me the
video where the person was
sitting on the chair.
And you can solve that problem.
You can also solve a
problem like generation.
I can give you a video
and I can tell you,
I don't know what's here.
Please describe it to me.
So if you see the scene, you
can say, what's on the screen?
Well, there's a whole bunch
of text on the screen.
You can also do
question answering.
You can take an image like this.
I can ask you a question.
What's the color of the font?
And you can say,
the font is white.
So you were able to take
some very high-level that's
in my head that got
transmitted to your head.
You were able to understand the
purpose of this transmission,
connect it to your perception,
figure out the knowledge that I
wanted extracted
from your perception,
and give it back to me in a
way that's meaningful to me.
Even more than this,
you can disambiguate.
You can take a sentence
that's extremely
ambiguous about the
world and figure out
what I'm referring to.
And we do this all the time.
That's really what makes human
communication possible, right?
The fact that most of what I
say is extremely ambiguous.
That's why programming
computers is a real pain,
but talking to people
is generally easier
depending on the person.
You can also acquire
knowledge, right?
You can look at a
whole bunch of videos.
If you're a child, you sort of
perceive the world around you.
Occasionally, an adult comes,
drops a sentence here or there
for you.
But what's important is that
no adult ever really points out
what the sentence
is referring to.
You don't know that
approach refers
to this particular vector when
someone was doing some action.
You know that Apple refers to
this particular object class.
Who knows what it could mean?
But you get enough
data, and you're
able to disentangle
this problem of seeing
weakly-supervised videos
paired with sentences.
And we'll see how
you can do that.
Pretty much everything
I'll talk about
is going to be about videos.
And I'll tell you
a story about how I
think we can do images as well.
There are a bunch
of other problems
that you can solve
with this approach.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: So those
images go with the video?
ANDREI BARBU: Yes.
So rather than doing videos,
we're going to do images.
So one thing that you can do is
you can try to do translation.
We haven't done this.
We're going to be
doing this in the fall.
We have two students.
And I'll tell you at the
end what the story is
for how you're going to do a
task that sounds as if it's
from language to
language, but you're
going to do it in a grounded
way that involves vision.
Even more than that,
you can do planning.
And I'll tell you about that
at the end a little bit.
And finally, you
can also incorporate
some theory of mind.
And that's actually the
project that the students are
doing as part of summer school.
And I'll say a few
words about that.
What's important about this
is the parts at the top,
we understand better.
We've published
papers about them.
The parts at the bottom are
sort of more future work,
and I'll say less about them.
Well, one important
part about this
is I've shown you
all these tasks.
But you really
have to believe me
that humans perform
these tasks all the time.
Every time you're sitting at
a table and you ask someone,
give me a cup.
That's a really hard
vision language task.
There may be 10 different cups
inside of you on the table
if you're sitting on one
of the big, round tables.
And you have to figure out,
what object am I talking about?
What kind of cup
am I talking about?
Which cup would I
be interested in?
If I drank out of the cup, I
would expect that you give me
my cup, not your cup.
Otherwise, let me know.
I will sit at different
tables from now on.
If I ask you, which
chair should I sit in?
Again, you have to solve
a pretty difficult problem
where you look at chairs.
You figure out what I mean by
which chair should I sit in.
Is it that there's a chair
that's reserved for someone.
Is it that a chair
is for a child
and I'm an adult,
that kind of thing.
You can say something
like this is an apple.
And when you say
that to a child,
you're saying it for
a particular reason.
To convey some idea.
You have to coordinate your gaze
with the other person's gaze
to make sure you're
drawing their attention
to the real object.
Even more than that, you can
say very abstract things,
like to win this game, you have
to make a straight line out
of these pieces.
That means that we both
agree on what a piece is.
That I've drawn your attention
to the right idea of a piece.
That we agree on
what a straight line
means on this particular board.
There's a lot of knowledge
that goes into each of these.
But the important part
is that they're each
grounded in perception.
We have to agree on what we're
seeing in front of each other
in order to be able to
exchange this information.
And pretty much everything that
we do in daily communication
is a language-vision
problem on some level.
All right.
So if we believe these
problems are important,
we can make one
other observation,
which is none of
you got training
in most of these problems.
No adult ever sat you
down and said, OK.
Now, you're four.
Now I'm going to teach
you how to ask questions
about the real world.
Or no one sat you
down and said, OK.
Now, let's talk about
language acquisition.
You're supposed to
do gradient descent.
So what's important is you have
some core ability that's shared
across all of these tasks?
And you're able to
acquire knowledge,
maybe in one of these tasks
or across all of these tasks.
You're able to put it together.
And as soon as you
have this knowledge,
you can use this for
all these other tasks
without having to
learn anything else.
And that's what
we're going to see.
And the core of this that
we're going to focus on
is recognition.
So we're going to
build one component.
This is that engineering
portion of the talk.
We're going to build one
scoring function that
takes a sentence in a video
and gives you a score.
How well does this
sentence match this video?
If the score is 1, it
means the system really
believes the sentence is
depicted by the video.
If the score is 0, it
means the system really
believes the sentence does not
occur anywhere in this video.
And this is the
basic thing that's
going to allow us to connect our
top-down knowledge about what's
going on in the world with
our low-level perception.
And after we have
this, we're going
to see how we reformulate
everything in terms of this one
function, so we
don't have to learn
anything else about the world.
All right.
So we said we need this one
function, scoring function
between sentences and videos.
So let's look at
what we would need
to have inside this
function in the first place.
If I give you a video like
this, it's just a person
riding a skateboard.
And I give you a sentence.
The person rode the
skateboard leftward.
Well, I can ask you, is the
sentence true of this video?
Indeed, it is true.
But let's think
about what you had
to do in order to be able
to answer this question.
Well, you had to at some level
decide there's a person there.
I'm not saying that
you're doing this
in this order in your brain.
I'm not saying that they
have to be individual stages.
I'm not saying you have to
have to object detectors.
But at some point, you
had to decide there really
is a person there somehow.
You also had to decide
there is a skateboard there.
You had to look at these
objects over time, or at least--
in at least one or
two frames decide
that they have a
particular relationship,
so that the person
isn't flying in the air
and the skateboard
continues onwards.
And you had to look at this
relationship and decide, yeah.
OK, this is writing.
And it's happening leftward.
So you have to have these
components on some level.
You've got to see the objects.
You've got to see the
relationships, the static
and the changing relationship
between the objects.
And you have to have some way
of combining those together
to form some kind
of sentence you
can represent that knowledge.
And that's what
we're going to do.
Everything I described to you
is this feed-forward system,
right?
We had objects.
We have tracks.
We take tracks and
we build events.
Events like ride.
And we take those
events together
and we form sentences
out of them.
And there's this hard
separation, right?
It's easy to understand a
system where what you do
is you have objects, tracks,
events, and sentences.
And you use tracks in order
to see if your events happened
and your events in order to
see if a particular sentence
occurred.
So that's what we're
going to describe first,
and then we're going to
see how, because we're
going to choose the right
representations for each
of these, these feedbacks become
completely trivial and very
natural to implement.
All right.
We need to start with
some object detections.
Otherwise, we're just going
to hallucinate objects
all the time.
Any off-the-shelf object
detector that you choose
will sometimes work.
Here, we ran a person detector
in red and a bag detector
in blue.
It will sometimes give
you false positives.
Trees are often
confused for people.
I guess we're both
two vertical-- two
long, vertical lines.
And sometimes, you
get false negatives.
Sometimes, a bag
is so deformable
that you think the
person's knee is the bag.
Lest you think that object
detection is solved,
it actually isn't.
So if you look at something
like the image net challenge,
mostly people talk about
the image classification.
The stuff in light blue.
And they're saying
that there's 10% error.
These days, there's
5% error on this.
But that's really not what
you're doing in the real world.
You're not classifying
whole images.
When you see an image in the
real world, what you're doing
is you're trying to figure
out what objects are where.
And that's the red part.
That's the part where you have
an average precision of 50%.
In other words, the
object detector really,
really, really sucks.
Most of the time, it's
going to be pretty wrong.
It's very, very, very far away
from how accurate you are.
If your object
detector was that bad,
you would die every time
you crossed the street.
All right.
So we believe that object
detection doesn't work well.
In order to fix this,
because somehow we
have to be able to extract
some knowledge about the video
that's pretty robust for us to
be able to track these objects
and recognize
these sentences, we
need to modify object
detectors a little bit.
We're going to go into
our object detector.
And normally, they
have a threshold.
At some point, they learn that
if the score of this detection
is above this level, I
should have confidence in it.
And if the score of this
detection is below this level,
I shouldn't have
confidence in it.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to remove that threshold.
We're going to tell
the object detector,
give me thousands or millions
of detections in every frame.
We're going to take
those detections
and we're going to figure out
how to filter them later on.
All right.
The way we're going
to do this-- and this
is the only slide that's
going to have any equations.
And it's just going to
be a linear combination.
All we're going to
do is we're going
to take every detection in
every frame of this video.
We're going to arrange
them in the lattice.
In every column of
this lattice, we're
going to have the detections
for one particular frame.
And in essence, what we
want is one detection
for every object
for every frame.
In other words, we want the
path through this lattice.
We want to select one
detection in every column.
But we want tracks that have
a particular property, right?
If I'm approaching
this microphone,
you know that you expect
to see me kind of far away.
Then, getting closer.
Then, eventually I'm
close to the microphone.
You don't expect me
to be over there,
and then to appear over
here as if I've teleported.
So we want to build
this intuition
that objects move smoothly.
And that objects move according
to how they previously
moved, right?
It's not like someone moves
from one frame 10 pixels over.
Then, the next frame, they
move 10 pixels to the left.
And they keep oscillating
between the two.
And that's what
we're going to do.
I'm not going to talk
about how we compute this.
It's really trivial.
If you know about optical
flow, you can do it.
But basically, what we
want is a track where we
don't hallucinate the objects.
So every node in our resulting
detections should be strong.
If we ignore the strength
of the object detector,
we're just going to
pretend that there
are a whole bunch of
people in front of us.
And every edge should
also be strong.
In other words, when we
look at two detections
from adjacent frames, if I have
a person over here in one frame
and a person over
here in another frame,
I shouldn't really think that's
a very good person track.
But if I have a person over
here that kind of moved
to the right the
previous frame and I
have a new detection
that's just slightly
to the right of that
one, I should expect
that it's a much better track.
So that's all we do.
And encoding this intuition
is very, very straightforward.
It's just a linear combination.
So the score of
one path, the score
of the track of
an object, is just
the sum of your confidence
in the detections.
So in every detection
and every frame,
along with the confidence
that the object track
was actually coherent.
All right.
So is the only equation we're
going to see in this talk.
And it's just a
linear combination.
But it will come
back to haunt us
several times before the end.
All right.
So we use dynamic programming.
We find the path
through this lattice.
And this is a tracker.
And actually, Viterbi did
this in 1967 for radar.
This is not a new idea.
Here, we ran it for just
a computer vision task
where we just wanted
to track objects.
We ran a person detector
and a motorcycle detector,
but we don't have a
person standing up
and a person sitting
down detector.
So the tracker is
good enough that it
can keep the two people
separate from each other,
despite the fact
that they're actually
pretty close in the video.
So you see we do a pretty decent
job of tracking all the objects
until they get pretty
small in the field of view
and the object detector
doesn't work well anymore.
All right.
So now what we have are
the tracks of objects.
We can see object motion
over time and from a video.
And somehow, we have
to look at these tracks
and determine what
happened to them.
Was someone riding?
Was someone running?
Was someone bouncing
up and down?
In order to do this, we're
going to get some features
from our tracks.
You can look at the
track in every frame
and you can extract out
a lot of information.
You can extract out
the average color.
You can extract out the
position, the velocity,
acceleration, aspect ratio.
Anything that you
want to get out
of this frame knowing that
this bounding box is there,
you can compute and the
algorithm doesn't care.
All right.
There's one small
problem, though.
Most of the time, we need more
complicated feature vectors.
So for example
for ride, it's not
enough to have a feature vector
that only includes the person.
You needed to look at
the relative position
between the person
and the skateboard
to determine-- that are
actually going together
and one isn't going right and
the other one is going left.
So for that, what we're
going to do is we're
going to build a feature vector
for the agent of the action
in the case of ride
and a feature vector
for the instrument--
the skateboard.
We're going to concatenate
the two together,
so we get a bigger
feature vector.
And then we're going to have
some extra features that
tell us about the relationships
between these two.
So we can include things
like the distance,
the relative velocity,
the angle, overlap.
Anything that you want to
compute between these two
bounding boxes in this frame,
you're welcome to compute.
All right.
And if you build this feature
vector between this person
and the skateboard, you could
recognize the person rode
the skateboard in this video.
If you build a different
feature vector,
for example between
these two people,
you could recognize the
person was approaching
the other person, or the person
was leaving the other person.
If you build a feature
vector between the skateboard
and the other person,
you could recognize
the skateboard is approaching
the person, et cetera.
So depending on which
feature vector you build,
you can recognize
different kinds of actions.
So when we have our tracks,
we know how the objects
moved in these videos.
We get out some feature
vectors from our tracks.
And what we need to do is decide
what these feature vectors
are actually doing.
Is the person riding
that skateboard?
The way we're going to do this
is using hidden Markov models.
Hidden Markov models
are really simple.
All they assume is
that there is a model
of the world that follows a
particular kind of dynamics.
In this case, imagine that we
have an action like approach.
I'm far away from the object.
I get closer to the object.
Eventually, I'm
next to the object.
So this action, for
example, has three states.
One where I was far, one
as I was getting nearer,
one when I was very close.
And we have a
particular transition
between these states, right?
We already said that
I don't teleport.
So I shouldn't be able
to go from being far away
to being near.
So you should expect me
to go from the first state
to the second state
and to the third state
without going from
the first to the last.
In each state,
you have something
that you want to
observe about me, right?
You want to really see that I'm
far away in the first state,
that I'm getting
closer in the second,
and I'm actually
there in the third.
So we have some model for what
we expect to see in every state
and we can connect this
with our feature vectors.
So the idea is
there's some hidden
information behind the
motion of these objects.
And we're going to assume
that hidden information is
represented within HMM.
And what we need to
recover is the real state
of these objects.
So if you see a video of me
moving towards this microphone,
you have to recover some
hidden information of,
which frames was far away in?
Which frames was getting nearer?
And which frames was I
actually next to the object?
For now what we're
going to do is
we're going to assume that we
have one of these hidden Markov
models for every different word.
So for every verb, we have a
different hidden Markov model.
There's one for approach.
There's one for pickup.
There's one for ride, et cetera.
And if you want to tell me
what's going on in this video,
you just have a big library
of hidden Markov models.
You apply every
one to every video.
You have some threshold.
And anything above that
threshold, you say happened.
And you produce a
sentence for it.
OK.
If we look at how you
actually figure out
what this hidden information
is, what state am I
in when I'm approaching
this object,
it looks a lot like the tracker.
What you have is you have to
make a choice in every frame.
Your choice is, which
state is my action in?
Is it state 1 through
3, or some other state?
In the same way that in tracker,
you have to make a choice.
You have to choose,
which detection is
the system in for each frame?
And here, you also have edges.
Edges tell you, how
likely am I to transition
between different
states in my action?
And every node also has a score.
It's the score of,
did you actually
observe me doing what
you're supposed to observe
me doing in every action?
So if you're saying
I'm in the first state,
did you actually see me
stationary and far away
from that object?
And what you want is a
path through this lattice
in the same way that
we had a path before.
And a path just means
you made a decision
that I'm in state 1
in the first frame
or in state 1 in the
third frame, et cetera.
And that's just the linear
combination of the scores.
So it's the same
equation we saw before.
So here's an example of this
sort of feed-forward pipeline
in action.
We ran it over a
few thousand videos.
It produces output like the
person carried something,
the person went away, the person
walked, the person had the bag.
It's pretty limited
in its vocabulary.
It has 48 verbs, about
30 different objects,
a few different prepositions.
And it even works
when the camera moves.
So the person chased
the car rightward,
the person slowly ran
rightward to the car.
And it should also probably
say the person had a really bad
day, but that's for the future.
So we've seen this
feed-forward pipeline.
We've seen that we
can get objects.
We can get tracks.
We can look at our
tracks, get some features,
run event detectors, take
those event detectors,
and produce some sentences.
And now, all we're
going to do is
we're going to break down
the barriers between these
and show you how you can have
feedback in a really, really
simple way.
All right.
So first, let's combine our
event detector and our tracker.
Because what that's
going to say is,
if you're looking for someone
riding something, well,
you should be biased
towards seeing people
that are riding something.
So in the occlusion
example, if you
see someone go behind
some large pillar,
well, you might lose them.
But you have a bias that you
should reacquire someone riding
a skateboard after
they leave the pillar,
which you don't have if you just
run the tracker independently
from the event detector.
So the way we're going
to put them together
is very, very easy.
There's a reason why these
two look completely identical
and why the inference algorithm
between them is identical.
Right now, what we're doing is
we have a tracker on the left,
or on your left.
And we have an event
recognizer on the right.
Right now, we're running
one, and then we're
feeding the output of
one into the other.
Basically, we run
one maximization,
and then we run
another maximization.
And all we're
going to do is move
the max on the
right to the left.
And you get the exact
same inference algorithm.
The intuition behind this
is you have two lattices.
And you can take the
cross-product of the lattices.
Basically, for
every tracker node,
you just look at all the
event recognizer's nodes
and you make one big
node for each of those.
And every node
represents the fact
that the tracker
was in some state
and the event recognizer
was in some other state.
So we have a node that
says the tracker chose
the first detection.
The event recognizer
was in the first state.
We have another node that
says the tracker chose
the second detection.
The event recognizer was
still in the first state.
And you do this for
every detection.
Then, you do the same thing
for the event recognizer
being the second
state, et cetera.
So you're just taking
a cross-product
between all of the states.
Does that make sense?
Another way to say it is that
we have two Markov chains.
One that's observing the
output from the object detector
and another one that's observing
the output of the middle Markov
chain.
And you do joint
influence over them.
And the way you can
do joint inference
is by taking the cross-product.
Basically, you have two
hidden Markov models.
One that does tracking and one
that does event recognition.
And all we're going to
do is joint difference
in both of them.
So rather than trying to
choose the best detection,
and then the best
state for my event,
I'm going to jointly
figure out, what's
the best detection if I
assume I'm in this state?
What's the best detection if I
assume I'm in this other state?
And at the end, I'll pick
the best combination.
Make sense?
So this is a way for
your event recognizer
to influence your tracker,
because now you're
jointly choosing the best
detection for both the tracker
and the event recognizer.
So that was really,
really simple.
We put in a tremendous
amount of feedback
by just taking a cross product.
So we can see this in action.
I'm going to show you
the same video twice.
The person is not going to
move in this video at all.
What we told the system is that
a ball will approach a person.
That's it we didn't
tell them which person.
We didn't tell the system
which particular ball,
which direction it's
going to come from,
or anything like that.
The top detection in this
frame happens to be the window.
It's a little hard to see.
It's quite a bit
stronger than the person.
But because neither the
window nor the person
ever move in this
scenario, the tracker
can't possibly help you.
You have no motion information.
The only way to override
that window detection
is to know something
else about the world.
So we told it that the
ball will approach.
And you can see that for the
combined tracker and event
recognizer.
Indeed, when the ball comes into
view, it will make more sense.
So the reason why we actually--
coming back to the question
that you asked.
Why we don't run it
over small windows
is because we want this effect
of knowledge that's much,
much later on in the video.
Like the fact that the
ball will enter or approach
that person as
opposed to that window
to actually help you much
earlier in the video.
If you run it over small
windows, you lose that effect.
So here, you track the person
correctly from the very first
frame despite the fact that
the ball only comes into view
halfway through the video.
There are many more
examples of this.
In this case, it's a
person carrying something.
Here, we told the system one
person's carrying something.
And you'll see when
the person moves,
we can detect the
person and the bag.
The object detector fails much,
much earlier because the person
was deformable.
So we've seen how we can combine
together trackers and events
recognizers.
And now, we need
to add sentences.
And the trick for
adding sentences
is going to do more of the same.
What we're going to do is
we're going to take a tracker.
It's just exactly
what we saw before.
And what we just
did a moment ago
is we combined it with
an event recognizer.
Well, there's no reason why
we can't add more trackers.
We actually kind
of did that, right?
We were tracking both a person
and a ball a moment ago.
So we can take an even
bigger cross-product,
have multiple trackers,
and have multiple words.
So all we're saying
is, I have, say,
five trackers that are running.
I have five words
that I want to detect,
or 10 words that
I want to detect.
And I want to make the choice
for all of these 5 trackers
jointly, so that they match
all of these 10 words.
In this picture,
basically our words
are kind of-- our sentences
are kind of like bags of words,
right?
Every word is combined
with every tracker.
But we know if you look at
the structure of a sentence
like the tall person
quickly rode the horse,
not every word refers to
every object in the sentence.
So you can run your object
detectors over your video.
And you can look
at your sentence.
And you can look at
the nouns and say, OK.
So I have people and
horses inside the sentence.
And you can say, OK.
Well, if I have people and
horses, I need two trackers.
But you can look a little
bit more at your sentence
and see that, oh, well,
it's the other horse.
So you analyze your
sentence and you
can determine there are three
participants in the event
described by the sentence.
There's a person and two horses.
One's the agent.
One's the patient-- the
thing that's being ridden--
and one's source-- the
thing that is being left.
Does that make sense?
Awesome.
So now, given a sentence, we
know that we need n trackers.
And for every word, we can
have a hidden Markov model.
We can have a hidden
Markov model for ride.
It's just another verb.
And we just have to be
careful how we build
a feature vector for ride.
Because if we build
it in one way,
we're going to detect the
person rode the horse.
And if we build it
in the opposite way
by concatenating the vectors
the other way around,
we're going to detect the
horse rode the person, which
is not what we want.
We can also detect tall.
Tall is kind of a weird
hidden Markov model, right?
It has only a single state,
but it's still a hidden Markov
model.
It just wants to see
that this object is tall.
So maybe its aspect ratio is
more than the mean aspect ratio
of objects of this class.
But nonetheless, it still
fits into this paradigm.
We can do the same
thing for quickly.
We can have an HMR for that.
We can do leftward.
We can do away from.
Away from looks
a lot like leave.
It's the same meaning.
And basically, we end up
with this bipartite graph.
At the top, we have lattices
that represent words.
Each word has a
hidden Markov model.
And in the middle,
we have lattices
that represent trackers.
We can combine them together
according to the links.
And you can get these links
from your favorite dependency
parser.
You can get them from
Boris's START system.
Any language analysis
system will give you this.
So this is actually
all the heavy lifting
that we have to do.
Everything from now on
is kind of eye candy.
One thing that we really
wanted to make sure
that system was doing is
that we could distinguish
different sentences.
So we tried to come up
with an experiment that
is, in some way,
maximally difficult where
events are going to
happen at the same time.
So you can't use time in
order to distinguish them.
And the sentences only differ
in one word or one lexical item.
So in this case,
we have a sentence
like the person picked up an
object and person put down
an object.
There are two systems
that are running.
One is running on one sentence.
One is running on
the other sentence.
You're going to see
the same video played
twice side by side.
And you can already see
that one system, when
we primed it to
look for pickup, it
detected me picking
up my backpack.
And then, the other one
it detected one of my lab
mates picking up a bin.
So the only way you
could focus its attention
on the right object is if it
understood the distinction
between these two
sentences, or if it
was able to represent them.
So we can play this game
many, many times over.
We can have it pay
attention to the subject.
Is a backpack approaching
something or is a chair
approaching something?
We can have it pay attention
to the color of an object.
Is the red object approaching
something or a blue object
approaching something?
We can have it pay
attention to a preposition.
Is someone picking up an
object to the left of something
or to the right of something?
And we have many, many
dozens or hundreds of these.
And I won't bore you
with all of them.
But the important part is
we can handle lots and lots
of different parts of speech.
And we can still represent
them and we can still
be sensitive to these subtle
distinctions in the meanings
of the sentences.
All right.
So we did all the hard work.
And we actually built
this recognizer--
the score of a
sentence given a video.
And now, it turns
out that we can
reformulate all of
these other tasks
in terms of this one score.
And it's going to do all
the heavy lifting for us.
So when we tune the
parameters of whatever
goes into the scoring
function, we're
going to get the ability to
do all these other tasks.
So let's look at retrieval.
It's the most straightforward
kind of task, right?
It's what YouTube does for you.
You go to YouTube.
You type in a query, and YouTube
comes back with some answers.
So let's see what
YouTube actually does.
If you look at YouTube.
And if you look at
something like pickup,
you get men picking up women.
If you look at approach, you
get men picking up women.
If you look at put
down, once upon a time
you did get men
picking up women,
but rap is now more popular.
If you ask something more
interesting-- the person
approached the
other person-- you
don't get videos where
people approach each other.
You get videos about how
you should approach women.
I didn't select these.
I typed them in and this
is just what happened.
If you type in, like the
person approached the cat,
you get lots of people
playing with cats,
but no one approaching
cats, including
a link that's kind of scary
and an Airbus landing.
And I have no idea
what that means.
So what we did is we built a
video retrieval system that
actually understands what's
going on in the videos as
opposed to just
looking at the tags
that the people apply
to these videos.
People don't describe
what's going on.
People describe some
high-level concept.
So we took a whole bunch
of object detectors
that are completely of the
shelf for people and for horses.
And we took 10 Hollywood movies.
Nominally, they're all Westerns.
They involve people on horses.
And the reason why we
chose people on horses
was because people
on horses tend
to be fairly larger
in the field of view.
And given that object
detectors suck so much,
we thought we should kind
of help the system along
s best we could.
So we build a system.
It's a system that
knows about three verbs.
It knows about two
nouns, person and horse.
It knows about some
adverbs, quickly and slowly.
prepositions, leftwards,
rightwards, towards, away from.
And given this template,
you can generate about 200,
300 different sentences.
So we can type in something
like the person rode the horse.
And we can get a
bunch of results.
So you can see, we were in 90%
accurate in the top 10 results.
You can see these are really
videos of people riding horses.
The way this works is we took
one of these long videos.
We chopped it up into
many small segments
and we ran over each
individual segment.
You could run it
over the whole video,
but then it would just
classify the whole video
because it's an HMM
and would sort of adapt
to the length of the video.
We can also ask for
other kinds of queries,
like the person rode
the horse quickly.
You can see we get videos
that really are quicker.
We can ask for something
more ambitious,
like the person rode the
horse quickly rightward.
And we get videos where people
are riding horses rightward.
All right.
So we did the hard work of
building this recognition
system.
And we saw we can use it
for another task, which
is retrieval.
But let's do something else.
Let's do generation.
Someone asked about
generation earlier.
Generation is very
similar to retrieval.
In retrieval, what we had
was we had a fixed sentence
and we searched
over all our videos
to see which ones
were the best match.
Here, we have a fixed video.
And we're going to search
over all our sentences.
The only trick is you
have a language model,
so it can generate a
huge number of sentences.
But we're going
to see that's OK.
So we have a language model.
It's very, very small
model by Boris' standards,
or the standard of NLP.
We have only four verbs, two
adjectives, only four nouns,
some adverbs, et cetera.
But the important part is
even if we ignore recursion,
we have a tremendous
number of sentences.
And this model is
recursive, so we can really
generate an infinite number
of sentences from it.
But nonetheless, it
turns out that you
can search the space
of sentences very,
very efficiently and actually
find the global optimum.
And the intuition for why that's
true is pretty straightforward.
You can think of your sentence
as a constraint on what you
can see in the world.
The longer your sentence,
the more constrains you have.
So the lower the
overall score is.
So every time you
add a word, the score
can't possibly increase, right?
The score has to
always decrease.
So basically, you have this
monotonically-decreasing
function over a
lattice of sentences.
And if you ignore the
fact that you only
have to search sentences,
you can start off
with individual words,
aggregate words together.
So you look at all
one-word phrases.
You can a two-word phrases,
three-word phrases.
Eventually, get out
to real sentences.
But because this is a
monotonically-decreasing
function, this is a
very quick search.
So you can start off
with an empty set.
You can add a word.
For example, you
can add carried.
You can look at all the ways
that you can extend carried
with another word or two.
So you get a phrase
like the person carried.
And you can keep
adding words to it
until you get to
the global optimum.
So given a video
like this, where
you see me doing
something, you can
produce a sentence
like the person
to the right of the bin
picked up the backpack.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
We built a generator in
just a few lines of code
as long as we had our
recognition system.
So you have this problem
in question answering
that you have to connect
two sentences with a video.
And instead of doing that,
what we're going to do
is we're going to make
some connection between two
sentences.
So we're going to
take our question.
We're going to give it to
something like Boris' system.
And it's going to
tell us this question,
like, what did the person
put on top of the red car?
If you wanted to answer it,
you would produce an answer
like, the person put some noun
phrase on top of the red car.
So you can run the
generation system exactly
as was suggested.
You seed it with this.
You give it a
constraint that what
it has to produce next
inside this empty gap
is a noun phrase.
And you're going to
get out the answer.
Another way to
think about this is
you have sort of a
partial detector.
You look inside the video
to see where it matches.
You choose the best
region where it matches,
and then you complete
your sentence.
And you get an answer
like the person
put the pair on
top of the red car.
There's one small problem
with question answering,
and it differs from
generation in one way.
So imagine that we're
in a parking lot
and there are a hundred white
cars inside this parking lot.
And you come to me desperate
and you say, I lost my keys.
And I say, don't worry.
I know exactly
where your keys are.
And you look at me and I say,
they're in the white car.
And then you think I'm
a complete asshole,
because that was totally
worthless information, right?
I told you something
that's basically true.
It's a parking lot
full of white cars,
but isn't actually giving
you anything useful.
So to handle this--
in the same way
that in generation, we
had this one parameter
that we could tune to get, more
or less, for both sentences.
We're going to add
only one parameter
to question answering,
which is kind
of a truthfulness parameter.
Which basically is going to say,
this sentence, the person put
an object on top of the
red car in this video,
is very ambiguous, right?
It could either
be Danny that did
it or it could be me
that put something
on top of the red car.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to take this
candidate's answer.
We're going to run
it over the video.
And we're going to see how
many times it has really
close matches in the video.
And depending on
this one parameter,
we're going to say
you are allowed
to say more things
about the video
to become more specific about
what you're referring to.
But potentially, slightly
less true because the score
will be lower.
In the same way
that you were saying
slightly more in
the generation case
at the risk of saying
potentially something
that's slightly less true.
So this way, you can ignore the
sentence, which is unhelpful.
And you can end up
saying something
like, the person on
the left of the car
put an object on
top of the red car.
So we can actually do
that and the system
produces that output.
We built one
recognition approach.
And we did retrieval,
generation, and question
answering with it.
We can also do
disambiguation with it.
In disambiguation,
we take a sentence,
like Danny approached
the chair with a bag.
And you can imagine
that this sentence
can mean multiple things.
It could mean Danny was
actually carrying a bag
and approaching a chair.
Or it could mean there
was a bag on a chair
and Danny was approaching it.
And there's the
question of, how do
you decide which
interpretation for the sentence
corresponds to which video?
Basically, you can
take your sentences
and you can look at
their parse trees.
And you're going to see
that they're different.
Essentially, your
language system
is going to give you
a slightly different
internal representation
for each of these.
And we already know that
when we build our detectors
for the sentence, we take
these kinds of relationships
between the words as inputs.
So even though there's
one sentence in English
that described both of
these scenarios, when
we build detectors
we're going to end up
with two different detectors.
One for one meaning, one
for the other meaning.
And then we can just
run the detectors
and figure out which meaning
corresponds to which video.
And indeed, that's what we did.
Except that there
are lots and lots
of different
potential ambiguities.
There are different
kinds of attachment.
In the same case--
I won't go through all of them.
But for example, you might
not know where the bag is.
You might not know who's
performing the action.
You might not be
sure if both people
are performing the
action or only one person
is performing the action.
There may be some
problems with references.
So this is a very
simple example,
like Danny picked up
the bag in the chair.
It is yellow.
But this is the kind of
thing that you would see
if you had a long paragraph.
You would have some
reference later on
or earlier on to some person.
And you wouldn't be sure
who was the referent.
And it turns out that if you
have sentences like this,
you can disambiguate
them pretty reliably.
So what's important is it's
not just a case of parse trees.
We need a more interesting
internal representation.
And an example of how we do
this is we take a sentence
and we make some first-order
logic formula out of it.
So you have some variables.
The chair is something like x.
You have Danny, who
moved it, and I moved it.
Or in the other case, you
have two separate chairs.
And I moved one and
Danny moved the other.
And they're distinct chairs.
What we do is we first
ignore the people.
So we just say there
are two people.
And in both cases, we're
distinct from each other.
But we don't have person
recognizers, face recognition,
or anything like that.
Then for each of these
variables, we build a tracker.
And for every constraint,
we have a word model.
And essentially, you can go from
this first-order logic formula
to one of our detectors.
So it's exactly the
same thing as the case
where we had a
sentence and a video.
And we just wanted to see, is
the sentence true of the video?
Except that now we have
a sentence interpretation
and the video.
So we've seen that
if all you have
are multiple interpretation
of a sentence,
you can figure out which
one belongs to which video.
And we'll come back
to this in a moment,
because it's actually
quite useful.
So you can imagine
a scenario where
you want to talk to a robot.
And you want to
give it a command.
You don't want to play 20
questions with it, right?
You want to tell it something.
It should look at
the environment.
And it should figure out,
you're referring to this chair
and this is what
I'm supposed to do.
So the other reason
for disambiguation
is going to be because you
get a lot of ambiguities
while you're acquiring language.
So we're going to break
down language acquisition
into two parts.
One part is we want to learn the
meanings of each of our words.
And another one is we want to
learn how we take a sentence
and we transform it into
this internal representation
that we use to actually
build these detectors.
So if you look at
the first one, let's
say you have a whole
bunch of videos.
And every video comes
with a sentence.
You don't know what the
sentence is actually
referring to in the video.
When children are born, nobody
gives mothers bounding boxes
and tells them, put this
around the Teddy bear
so your child knows what
you're referring to.
So we don't get those.
We have this more
weakly-supervised system.
But what's important is we
get this data set and there
are certain correlations
in this data set, right?
We know the chair
occurs in some videos.
We know that backpack
occurs in others just
by looking at the sentence.
We know pickup occurs in others.
So basically, this
is the same thing
as training one, big
hidden Markov model.
Except that now we have
multiple hidden Markov models
that have a small amount
of dependency between them.
And I won't talk about this.
You'll have to take
my word for it.
You can look at the paper.
But it's identical to
the Baum-Welch algorithm.
Essentially, all you do is you
take the gradient through all
the parameters of
these words and you
can acquire their meanings.
There are lots of
technical issues with this,
but that's the general idea.
So we can also look
at learning syntax.
And this is something
that we haven't done,
but we really want to do.
And this is where disambiguation
work really comes into play.
So if I give you a
sentence, like Danny
approached the chair with a
bag, you feed it into a parser.
Something like
Boris' start system.
And you get potentially
two parse trees, right?
One for one
interpretation and one
for the other interpretation.
You take the video
and you can select
one of these parse trees.
That's the game we just
played a moment ago.
But imagine that we take Boris'
system and we brain damage
it a little bit.
Or we take some deep
network that does parsing
and we just randomize a
few of the parameters.
So now, rather than getting
a single or two parse trees
for our two interpretations,
we get 100 or 1,000
different parse trees.
We can take each
one of those and we
can see, how well does
this match our video?
And we get some
distribution over them.
Maybe we won't get a single
one that matches the best.
Maybe we'll get a
few that match well
and a bunch that match
really, really poorly.
So this provides a signal to
actually train the parser.
Essentially, you
have a parser that
produces a distribution
over parse trees.
You use the vision
system to decide
which of these parse trees
are better than others.
And you feed this information
back into the parser
and retrain it.
We haven't done this,
but it's in the pipeline.
And eventually, the
idea is that we're
going to be able
to close the loop
and learn the
meanings of the words
while we end up
learning the parser.
But that's further
down the line.
So lest you think
that there's something
remarkable about language
learning in humans,
actually lots of animals learn
language, not just humans.
And here's a cute example
of a dog that does something
that our system can't do.
And actually, no language
system out there can do.
So there's this paper,
but this is from PBS.
And what ended up
happening is this dog
knows the meaning of about
1,000 different words
because there are
labels that have been
attached to different toys.
So it has 1,000 different toys.
Each one has a unique name.
And if you tell the
dog, give me Blinky,
it knows exactly
which toy Blinky is.
And it has 100% accuracy
getting you Blinky
from it's big, big pile of toys.
So what they did is
they took 10 toys.
They put them behind the sofa.
And they added
one additional toy
that the dog has
never seen before.
They tested the dog
many times to make sure
that it doesn't have
a novelty preference
or anything like that.
And then they asked the
dog, bring the Blinky.
And you can see
the dog was asked.
It goes behind.
It quickly finds Blinky.
It brings it back.
And there we go.
And now, the dog
is really happy.
So now, the dog is going to be
asked, bring me this new toy.
Bring me the professor, or
whatever the toy is called.
It's a little less certain.
OK.
So it's going to
go behind and it's
going to look at
all the objects.
The toy with the
beard is the new one
that it hasn't seen before.
And it was there in
the previous trial.
So it looks around and
it's a little uncertain.
It doesn't quite
want to come back.
We're going to see
that we're going
to have to give it another
instruction in a moment.
He's going to call it
back and ask the dog
to do exactly the
same task again.
Isn't telling it anything new.
It's just to give it
some encouragement.
So looking around for some toy.
And it picks the--
you'll see in a moment.
It picks the toy that
it hasn't seen before,
because it's a new word.
And the dog is really happy.
And I think the human is even
happier that this actually
worked.
But the important part
is, there's this dog
that we normally don't associate
with having a huge amount
of linguistic ability.
But it's learning
language in a way
that is far more advanced
than anything that we have.
And it's learning it
in a grounded way,
like it hard to connect its
knowledge about what it sees
with these toys
to this new object
that it's never seen before
and understand this new label.
And dogs are not the only
animal that can do this.
There are many other
animals that can do this.
All right.
And of course, children
do this as well.
So there was a
question about the fact
that we're constantly
using videos here.
And we're very
focused on motion.
But of course, in many
of these sentences,
we were referring to
objects that were static.
So we're not only sensitive
to objects that are moving.
So for example, when
I said something
like it was the person
to the left of the car,
neither the person nor the car
were moving in that question.
It was the pair that was moving.
But there's an
interesting question,
what if you want to recognize
actions in still images?
After all, we can do it.
It probably didn't
involve looking at photos.
You know, 200 million years
ago when our visual system
was being formed.
So somehow, we take
our video ability
and we apply it to images.
And the way we're going to
do that is by taking an image
and predicting a video from it.
We haven't done this,
but we've done the part
where you can actually
get predicting motion
from single frames.
So the intuition
about why this works
is, if you look at this
image and I ask you,
how quickly is this
baseball moving?
You can give me an answer.
AUDIENCE: Not very quickly.
ANDREI BARBU: Not very quickly.
Right.
And if you look
at this baseball,
you can decide that it's
moving very quickly, right?
So the other story
in this talk is
I'm becoming more
and more American.
I started with the
Canadian flag and now I
ended up with baseball.
All right.
So you can clearly do this task.
There is good
neuroscience evidence
that people are doing
this fairly regularly.
Kids can do this, et cetera.
All right.
So now, what we did
is we went to YouTube
and we got a whole
bunch of videos.
Videos that contain cars or
different kinds of objects.
We had eight different
object classes.
And we ran a standard
optical flow algorithm just
off the shelf.
And this gives us an idea
of how the motion actually
happens inside this video.
Then, we discard the video.
And we only keep
one of the frames.
And we train a deep network.
This is the only time deep
networks appear in this talk.
That takes as input the image
and predicts the optical flow.
It looks a lot like
an auto-encoder,
except the input and the output
are different from each other.
And it turns out this
works pretty well.
It has similar performance to
actually doing optical flow
on the video with sort of a
crappier, earlier optical flow
algorithm.
So up until now are
things that we've done.
At the end I'll
talk briefly about
what we're doing in the future.
So one thing that you
can do is translation.
And you can cast translation
as a visual language task,
even though it sounds like it
has nothing to do with vision.
So if I give you a
sentence in Chinese,
you can imagine scenarios
for that sentence,
and then try to describe
them with another language
that you know.
This is very different from
the way people do translation
right now.
So right now, the
way it works is
you have a sentence,
like Sam was happy.
And you have a parallel corpus.
If you want to translate
into French, you go off you.
Get the Hansard corpus
and you get a whole bunch
of French and English
sentences that
are aligned with each other and
you learn the correspondence
between them.
Here, I translated into
[AUDIO OUT] Russian.
The important part
is in English,
there's no assumption
about the gender of Sam.
Sam is both a male
name and a female name.
But the problem is Romanian,
Russian, French, et cetera,
they really force you to specify
the gender of the people that
are involved in these actions.
And you have to go
through a certain amount
of [AUDIO OUT] really want to
avoid specifying their gender.
So here, we specify
the gender as male.
Here, we specify the
gender as female.
And if all you have is
statistical machine translation
system, you may get an
arbitrary one of these two.
And you may not
know that you've got
an arbitrary one of these two.
And there may be a terrible
faux pas at some point.
So this problem is not
restricted to gender.
And it occurs all the time.
For example, in Thai,
you specify your siblings
by age, not by their gender.
So if you have an English
sentence like my brother
did x, translating that
is quite difficult.
In English, you specify relative
time through the tense system,
but Mandarin doesn't have the
same kind of tense system.
In this language
that I never tried
to pronounce after the
first time that I tried,
you don't use
relative direction.
So you don't say the bottle
to the left of the laptop.
We all agree on a
common reference
frame like a hill or something.
Or we agree on
cardinal directions.
And you say, the bottle
to the north or something.
And these people are
really, really good
at wayfinding because
they constantly
have to know where north is.
Many languages don't
distinguish blue and green.
Historically, this
is not something
that languages have done.
It's pretty new.
For example, Japanese didn't
until a hundred years ago.
They only started distinguishing
the two fairly recently
when they started interacting
with the West more.
And many languages
don't set that boundary
at exactly the same place.
So one language,
you may say blue.
In another language, you
may have to say green.
In Swahili, you specify
the color of everything
as the color of x.
So like in English,
we have orange.
But in Swahili, I
could say the color
of the back of my cell phone.
And I expect you to know that's
blue as long as you can see it.
In Turkish, there is a
relatively complicated
evidentiality system.
So you have to fairly often
tell me why you know something.
So if you saw
somebody do something,
you have to mark that in
the sentence as opposed
to hearing it from someone else.
So if it's hearsay, you
have to let me know.
There are much more complicated
evidentiality systems
where you have to tell me, did
you hear it, did you see it,
did you feel it?
It can get pretty hairy.
So there are a lot
of reasons why just
doing the straightforward
sentence alignment
can really fail on you.
And you can make some
pretty terrible mistakes.
And more importantly,
you just won't know
that that made these mistakes.
So instead, what
we've been thinking
is sort of translation
by imagination.
So you take a sentence.
And it's a generative
model that we have that
connects sentences and videos.
And what you do is you sample.
You sample a whole
bunch of videos.
So basically, you imagine
what scenarios the sentence
could be true of.
You get your collection
from the generator.
You search over sentences
that describe these videos
and you output a sentence
that describes them
well in aggregate.
So basically, you just
combine your ability
to sample, which comes
from your recognizer,
and your ability to generate.
And you get a
translation system.
So you do a
language-to-language task
mediated by your understanding
of the real world.
Something else that you
can do is planning, which
I'll just say two words about.
All you do is--
[PHONE RINGING]
--in a planning task,
what you have is
you have a planning language.
I'm glad that
wasn't my cellphone.
You have a planning
language, right?
So you have a fairly
constrained vocabulary
that you can use to
describe your plans.
And this allows you to
have efficient inference.
Instead, you can imagine that
I have two frames of a video,
real or imagined, where
I have the first world.
I am far away from
the microphone.
I have the last world where
I'm near the microphone.
And I have an unobserved
video between the two.
People have work and
I've done some work
on filling in partially
observed videos.
So it's a very similar idea,
except that here we have
a partially-observed video.
And we know that this
partially-observed video
should be described by
one or more sentences.
So we're going to do the same
kind of sampling process, where
we sample from this
partially-observed video
and we try to describe
what the sentence is.
And now you're doing planning.
You're coming up
with a description
of what had happened in this
missing chunk of the video.
But your planning
language is English,
so you get to take
advantage of things
like ambiguity, which
you couldn't take
advantage of in many languages.
Theory of mind.
The idea here is relatively
straightforward as well.
So what we have
right now, basically
are two hidden Markov models.
Or two kinds of hidden
Markov models, right?
There's a video.
We have some hidden Markov
models that are tracks
and we have some hidden Markov
model that look at the tracks
and they do some
inference about what's
going on with the
events in these videos.
So now imagine that
I had a third kind.
A third kind of hidden
Markov model that
only looks at the trackers.
Doesn't look at
the words directly.
And what it does is it
makes another assumption
about the videos.
So first, we assume the objects
were moving in a coherent way.
Then, we assumed
that the objects
were moving according to the
dynamics of some hidden Markov
models.
Now, we're going to
assume that people
move according to some
dynamics of what's
going on inside our heads.
So you can assume that I
have a planner inside my head
that tells me what I
want to do and what
I should do in the future
to accomplish my goals.
And you can look at a sequence
of my actions and try to infer.
If you believe this planner
is running in my head,
what do you think
I should do next?
Now, the nice part about
many of these planners
is that they look a lot like
this hidden Markov models.
And the inference algorithms
look a lot like these models.
So basically, you can do
the same kind of trick
by assuming that
HMM-like things are
going on inside people's heads.
So you can do things
like predict actions,
figure out what people want
to do in the future, what
they did in the past.
That's what the project is.
I want to show you another
example of vision and language,
but in a totally different
domain that I won't talk about,
which is in the case of robots.
This is something that we
built several years ago.
This is a robot that
looks at a 3D structure.
It's built out of Lincoln Logs.
They're big.
They're easier for the robot
to manipulate than LEGOs.
The downside is
they're all brown,
so it's very difficult
to do vision on this.
But it actually
will, in a moment,
reconstruct the 3D
structure of what it sees.
And we annotated and
read what errors it made.
We didn't tell it this.
What it does is it
measures its own confidence
and it figures out what
parts are occluded.
So it has too
little information.
And it plans another view.
It goes, it acquires it by
measuring its own confidence.
This view is actually worse
than the previous view,
but it's complementary.
So it will actually gain the
information that it's missing.
And all of this comes from the
same kind of generative model
trick that I showed
you a moment ago.
A similar model, it just
makes different assumptions
about what's built into it.
So now, because we have
a nice generative model,
we can integrate the
two views together.
You're going to see in a moment.
It'll still make some mistakes.
It won't be completely confident
because there are some regions
that it can't see,
even from both views.
And then what we
told it is, OK, fine.
For now, ignore the second
view, take just the first few.
Here's a sentence.
Or in this case, a
sentence fragment.
The fragment is
something like, there's
a window to the left and
perpendicular to this door.
It'll just appear a moment.
And integrating this
one view that it
saw that it was uncertain about
with that one sentence, that's
also very generic and
applied to many structures,
determine that
these two completely
disambiguate the structure.
And now, it's perfectly
confident in what's going on.
And it can go and
it can disassemble
the structure for you.
And we can play this
game in many directions.
We can have the robot
describe structures to us.
We can give it a description
and it can build the structure.
One robot can describe
the structure in English
to another robot who
can build it for it.
And it's exactly the
same kind of idea.
You connect your vision
and your language model
to something in the
real world, and then you
can play many, many
different tricks
with one internal representation
without modifying it at all.
But I realized yesterday
that I was the last speaker
before the weekend,
so I want to end
by leaving you as depressed
as I possibly can,
and tell you all the wonderful
things that don't work.
And how far away we are
from understanding anything.
So first of all,
we can't generate
the kind of coherent stories
that Patrick looks at.
Really, if you look at a
long video, what we can do
is we can search or we
can describe small events.
A person picks something up.
They put it down.
What we can say is the
thief entered the room
and rummaged around and
ran away with the gold.
That's the kind of thing
that you want to generate.
It's the kind of thing
that kids generate,
but we're not there yet.
Not even close.
We also only reason in 2D.
There's no 3D reasoning here.
And that significantly hurts us.
Although, we have some ideas
for how we might do 3D.
Another important aspect is we
don't know forces and contact
relationships.
Now, that's fine
as long as pickup
means this kind of
action where you
see me standing next to an
object and the object moving
up.
But sometimes, pickup means
something totally different.
So you're going to see
this cat is going to pickup
that kitten in just a moment.
And you're going to see
if you pay attention
to the motion of the
cat, that it doesn't look
like it's picking something up.
It's not very good at picking
up the kitten, mind you.
I think this may
be its first try.
I think it's having a good day.
It's OK.
Struggling a little bit.
But see?
So definitely, picked it up.
But it didn't look anything
like any of the other pickup
examples I showed you.
But conceptually,
you should totally
recognize this if you've
seen those other examples.
And kids can do this.
So the important
part is you have
to change how you
reason you can't just
reason about the relative
motions of the objects.
You have to assume that there
are some hidden forces going
on.
And you have to reason
about the contact
relationships and the
forces that the objects are
undergoing.
What happens if you try to
recognize a helicopter picking
something up.
It looks totally different
from a human doing it,
but no one has any
problems recognizing this.
Segmentation is
also a huge problem.
For many of these
problems, you have
to pay attention to the fine
boundaries of the objects
in order to understand that
that kitten was being rotated
and then slightly lifted.
There's also a more
philosophical problem
about what is a part
and what it means
for something to be an object.
We arbitrarily say that
the cat is an object,
but I could refer to its paws.
I could refer to its ears.
I could refer to one
small patch on its back.
As long as we all know
what we're talking about,
that can be our object.
And that's a problem
throughout computer vision.
It also occurs in a
totally different problem.
So if you've ever
seen Bongard problems,
there are these problems where
you have these weird patches,
and you have to figure out
what's in common between them.
And that's the
case where you have
to dig deep into
your visual system
to extract a completely
different kind of information.
And this is an
example that I prefer.
So in this task, you can
try to find the real dog.
And we can all spot it after
you look for a little while.
Right?
Does everyone see it?
OK.
So you can all see it
The interesting part is--
I mean, I doubt you
have ever had training
detecting real dogs amongst
masses of fake dogs.
But somehow, you were
able to adapt and extract
a completely different
kind of information
from your visual system.
Information that isn't
captured by our feature vector,
as I talk about the color,
location, velocity, et cetera.
So you have this
ability to extract out
task-specific information.
You can do things
like theory of mind,
but you can do far
more than assume
people are writing a planner.
You can detect if I'm sad.
If I'm happy.
You can reason about
whether two people
are having a particular
kind of interaction.
Who's more powerful
than the other person.
You also have a very strong
physics model inside your head
that underlies much of this.
And even more than that, there's
the concept of modification.
So walking quickly looks very
different from running quickly.
And the way you model
these is quite complicated.
And the system that I presented
doesn't do a good job of it.
But one of my favorite
examples from my childhood
long ago is this one, which
is a kind of modification.
So coyote is going to draw this.
You're going to see
the Roadrunner try
to run through it.
And he makes it.
And you can imagine what's
about to happen next.
Coyote is not going
to have a good day.
So this looks silly, right?
And you would think to yourself,
how could we possibly apply
this to the real world?
But actually, this happens in
the real world all the time.
A cage can be open for a mouse,
but closed for an elephant.
So if you're going to
represent something like,
is something closed
or not, you have
to be able to handle
situations like this.
And that's why
kids can understand
really weird scenarios like
this because they're not
so outlandish.
There's also the problem
of the vast majority
of English verbs--
things like absolve, admire,
anger, approve, bark, et
cetera.
All of them require
far more knowledge.
They require many of the things
I've talked about before.
And actually, far
more than them.
And what's even worse
is we also use language
in pretty bizarre ways.
So there are some kinds
of idioms in English,
like the market
[AUDIO OUT] bullish,
that you have to have seen
before to understand, right?
There's no reason
to assume that bears
are better or worse than
bulls when you apply them
to the stock market.
On the other hand,
there are certain things
that are very systematic.
I can have an up
day or a down day,
because we've both kind of as a
culture agreed that up is good
and down is bad.
Some cultures have made
the opposite choice.
But usually, it's up
is good, down is bad.
So an idea can be grand
or it can be small.
Because we've decided big things
are better than small things.
Someone's mood can
be dark or light.
And these are very
systematic variations
that underlie all of language.
And we constantly use
metaphoric extension
in order to describe
what's going on around us
and to talk about
abstract things.
It really seems as if
this is kind of built-in
to our model of the world.
And modeling this is
kind of over the horizon.
And there are many,
many, many other things
that we're missing here.
So I just want to thank all
my wonderful collaborators,
like Boris, Max, Candace,
and people at MIT, and people
elsewhere.
But to recap, what
we saw is that we
can get a little bit of
traction on these problems.
We can build one system that
does one simple problem just
connects our perception with
our high-level knowledge,
takes a video and a sentence
and gives us a score.
And once we have this
interesting connection,
this interesting feedback
between these two
very different-looking
systems, it
turns out that we can do
many different and sometimes
surprising things.